well well  who do i spy but be in my humble parlor  no less  mucaco long time no  so what brings you here  we have some outstanding biz to sell  remember sandra dorsett  i don't forget such things fee  here is your reward it comes with a  fairly ample bonus  go see a ripple dock they'll weave you a  dermal imprint that will enable smart  gun compatibility  a tiger class specialty  what they did  [Music]  definitely  hey v got this client not the brightest  bulb in the bunch  got himself into some serious trouble  needs to leave town asap  more intel attached  me  all ncpd subconscious apb out the  suspect  organized crime activities wall street  shipyard way  scavengers led by elena sidorova  presumed armed and dangerous  have assaulted multiple homeless persons  night city  officials are offering a report for  neutralizing the threat  let's see what's good  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  man  [Music]  oh